Start der ersten artemis-rakete gebaut
für die Reise zum Mond bald soll sie
Astronauten auf den Erdtrabanten bringen
doch was wenn etwas schief geht kurz
nach dem Start wie zum Beispiel beim
Starship Testflug von SpaceX
beim Startabbruch einer bemannten Rakete
ist die einzige Hoffnung der Astronauten
in ihrer Kapsel eine Notwasserung
wahrscheinlich irgendwo draußen im
Atlantik weit weg von Rettungsbooten
also nicht wie bei kontrollierten
wasserlandungen die einzige schnelle
Methode für Retter die Kapsel zu
erreichen sind Helikopter wie hier bei
der Rettung einer Bootsbesatzung doch
bei Sturm und hohen Wellen sind die
Hubschrauber selbst in ständiger Gefahr
abzustürzen die Retter müssen für den
schlimmsten Fall ausgebildet werden
das geschieht in speziellen Anlagen sie
simulieren die Naturgewalten auf offener
See Astronaut alexander Gerst hat so ein
Training bereits absolviert
besonders krass ist es wenn hier drin
dunkel gemacht wird Wellengenerator an
ist Sound Generator Anis und noch Wind
übers Wasser bläst stroke Generator
erzeugt Blitze und man muss praktisch
wohl alle Sinne geblendet sind man
nichts mehr hört sieht riecht schmeckt
aus diesem Helikopter rauskommen das
Rettungsboot aufblasen dann da rein
klettern und dann wird noch einem Kuh
Mitglied gesagt Erde sie muss
rausspringen Mann über Bord spielen und
die anderen müssen das dann entdecken
und den wieder reinziehen
Niederlande Rotterdam der europort hier
werden Menschen auf Helikopter Abstürze
vorbereitet unter der Leitung von
sicherheitsingenieurin Liebke
Astronauten und ihr Einsatzteam
durchlaufen hier die gleiche Ausbildung
wie Besatzungen von Gas und
ölbohrplattformen wenn beim Flug über
den Atlantik etwas schief geht geht es
um Leben und Tod
ja kann immer passieren dass in so einer
Situation irgendwas mit dem Triebwerken
ist die Rotoren nicht mitspielen und
auch dann muss man natürlich in der Lage
sein falls es zu einem Absturz kommt
sich aus diesem Helikopter wieder zu
befreien und das ist was wir mit dem
Helikopter underwater escape-training
trainieren in dem
Swimmingpool und da trainieren wir mit
den Leuten die auf den Plattform auf in
den Windpark sind wie Sie solche
Situationen am besten meistern können
mit der limitierten Hilfe die sie von
außerhalb erwarten können quasi nämlich
keiner
auch die Mitglieder des
astronauteneinsatzsteams der ESA müssen
lernen erstmal ohne Hilfe klar zu kommen
wenn Sie auf einer Rettungsmission zu
einer Astronauten Kapsel selbst mit
einem Helikopter verunglücken mit dabei
alexander Gerst als Astronaut und Leiter
des Astronauten einsatzsteams bei der
Isar in Köln damit das zum Tragen kommt
was ich heute hier lernen müssen zwei
Notfälle hintereinander eintreten und
zwar der erste ist das mein Freund und
Mannschaftskamerad an die morgen sind
mit seiner Weltraumkapsel notlanden muss
irgendwo im Atlantik bei schwerer See
und will dann rausfliegen müssen um ihn
zu retten und dann noch unser Helikopter
abstürzte dann kommt das zu tragen was
heute gelernt wird hier das heißt es
doch relativ unwahrscheinlich aber wenn
es dann passiert und solche Fälle sind
schon passiert dann muss man wirklich
das können was man hier gelernt hat wer
zu einem ESA Rettungsteam gehört muss
das spezielle Training alle zwei Jahre
durchlaufen sie fliegen in Helikoptern
aufs offene Meer hinaus wenn sie
gebraucht werden egal wie schlecht das
Wetter ist
knapp 1000 Kubikmeter Wasser fast der
Pool in dem der Absturz simuliert wird
mit einem Helikopter Dummy der an
Stahlseilen hängt ins Wasser taucht und
sich dabei überschlagen kann
alle teilnehmenden tragen
Trockentauchanzüge und Schwimmwesten mit
Rettungsgeräten das sind kleine
Druckluftflaschen mit Atemluft für
gerade mal 2 Minuten jeder Handgriff
muss hier sitzen und wird deswegen
wieder und wieder geprobt
auch ein gut trainierter Astronaut wie
alexander Gerst muss durch die Übungen
von Tauchteam Leiter Peter Kopp
Astronauten denken dass sie schon alles
wissen das ist der Unterschied wissen
sie es denn nicht
nicht alles selbst wenn er die Techniken
im Grunde beherrscht weiß alexander
Gerst wie wichtig das Üben ist im
Ernstfall gibt es keine zweite Chance
ist dabei tatsächlich wichtig das heißt
wenn ich da drin sitzt in diesem
Helikopter ich stelle mir wirklich vor
das ist jetzt ein wirklicher Helikopter
also ich versuche mich mental davon zu
verabschieden dass wir jetzt hier in
einem Pool sitzen dass das ein
Plastikmodell ist das ist erstmal egal
man versetzt sich in die Lage okay ich
bin jetzt hier wirklich in drei Meter
Wellen oder zehn Meter Wellen und der
Helikopter stürzt jetzt ab ich habe
jetzt noch 20 Sekunden bis zum auffallen
was mache ich
wenn der Helikopter untergeht geht es um
jede Sekunde im Atlantik wäre das Wasser
jetzt eiskalt und trüb die Insassen
müssen die Scheiben nach außen drücken
dann erst die Sicherheitsgurte lösen und
einen Fluchtweg finden ein Ausbilder ist
an Bord zwei sicherheitstaucher im
Becken sie helfen sofort wenn es
Probleme gibt nach knapp 20 Sekunden
sind alle aus dem Helikopter
für den Astronauten alexander Gerst
keine schwierige Übung aber eine die die
Sinne schärft und deren Anforderungen
gar nicht so weit entfernt sind von
denen im Weltall
die Gemeinsamkeit zwischen Wasser und
Weltall ist dass es eine ungewohnte
Situation für uns ist erstmal wenn man
uns als Menschen in kaltes Wasser wirft
dann schnappen wir erstmal nach Luft wir
sind desorientiert die Intuition
funktioniert nicht mehr so richtig
wenn man uns stark genug belastet können
wir vielleicht irgendwann mal Angst
bekommen oder in Panik verfallen das
sind alles Dinge die ganz normale
Menschen ihre Reaktionen sind und das
ist eine gute Trainingsumgebung für den
Weltraum weil auch der Weltraum ist
unintuitiv gefährlich immer da drin ist
man schwebt plötzlich man ist in engen
Plätzen man weiß vielleicht nicht mehr
wo oben und unten ist deswegen eine ganz
gute Trainingsumgebung das Trainings
Areal im Rotterdamer Hafen simuliert
verschiedene Szenarien
Ausbildungsleiterin Wiebke being möchte
die Teilnehmenden möglichst realistisch
auf das Chaos noch einem Helikopter
Absturz vorbereiten also im Grunde sitzt
man auf in dieser Plätze angeschnallt
mit einem Sicherheitsgurt und je nach
Szenario muss man entweder durch eins
dieser Fenster durch die Tür
durch ein anderes Fenster durch die
Kabine aus dem Helikopter raus das
bedeutet auch dass das Fenster dafür
vielleicht erst raus muss dass der
Helikopter vielleicht auf der Seite
liegt man von diesem Platz vielleicht
durch das Fenster muss oder von dem
Platz durch das Fenster oder vielleicht
durch die ganze Kabine je nachdem wo
irgendwas vielleicht blockiert sein
könnte kann es sein dass ein in einem
Helikopter wie diesem unterschiedliche
Szenarien erwarten es gilt vor allem
eine Panik unter Wasser zu verhindern
oder zu überwinden nichts für schwache
Nerven hinzukommt den richtigen Ablauf
verinnerlichen sobald der Helikopter
untergeht angeschnallt bleiben das
Fenster aufdrücken dann erst den Gurt
lösen und sich trotz des einsetzenden
Auftriebs seitlich durch den Ausstieg
schieben
dabei müssen manche Insassen erst warten
bis andere an ihn vorbei ins freie
Wasser geklettert sind
Ausrüstungsteile können sich dabei
verhaken oder passen nur schwer durch
die engen Ausstiege alles während der
Helikopter in der Realität kopfüber
immer tiefer ins Meer sinken würde
man muss sowohl körperlich als auch
mental in der Lage sein dieses Training
zu durchlaufen
mental sofern weil es nass eng eventuell
dunkel und auch
positionstechnisch schwierig ist und
körperlich man ist unter Wasser muss die
Luft anhalten und raus schwimmen das
kann sein dass sie einfach es nicht
schaffen unter Wasser anzufangen aus dem
Atemgerät zu atmen und dann kann es
einfach zur Panik kommen und dann werden
die Leute aber durch die Taucher
rausgezogen auch alexander Gerst übt mit
seinem kleinen Lebensretter der
Druckluftflasche in der Schwimmweste
jetzt ging so um dass wir unser kleines
Rettungsgerät hier gut verwenden können
jeder hat im Helikopter eine
Schwimmweste dabei und da ist ein
kleines Rettungsgerät mit der kleinen
Luftflasche drin und da hat man ungefähr
20 Atemzüge die man unter Wasser nehmen
kann das heißt eigentlich ist die Sache
ganz entspannt also man kann auch aus
einem umgedrehten Helikopter der singt
hat man genügend Zeit rauszukommen man
muss nur sein Equipment kennen darum
geht es gerade das wir haben das
herausgeholt und tatsächlich jetzt die
Flasche leer geatelt bisschen nichts
mehr drin waren und da merkt man schon
okay jetzt ist alle jetzt ist Zeit
aufzutauchen alexander Gerst taucht aus
dem Helikopter bei ihm sieht die Übung
leicht und problemlos aus es kommt auf
die richtige Mischung an aus
Konzentration und Vertrauen sowohl auf
die Technik als auch auf die eigenen
Fähigkeiten um fit zu sein für den
Ernstfall eines Rettungseinsatzes über
dem Atlantik oder die nächste Mission im
Weltraum
das Training ist natürlich wichtig für
die nächste Mission die ich selbst
unterstützen werde die nächsten Mission
meiner Kolleginnen und Kollegen zur
Internationalen Raumstation aber eben
auch die Artemision stehen an zu Mond da
hat dieser drei Slots dafür gesichert
das heißt 3 Europäerinnen Europäer
werden in den nächsten Jahren in
Richtung fliegen vielleicht bin ich
dabei ich würde mich natürlich freuen
und dafür ist so ein Training natürlich
auch nicht ganz schlecht und so ein
Training darf am Ende natürlich auch
Spaß machen und motivieren die letzte
Übung des Tages das ESA Astronauten
Einsatz Team bildet einen Block im
Wasser um niemanden zu verlieren und
dann in eine Rettungsinsel zu klettern
sie sind bereit falls das eintritt was
niemand von ihnen erleben möchte ein
Helikopter Absturz irgendwo im
Nordatlantik
[Musik]